hi everybody I'm Zhang accompli I just
went through my naturalization for
citizenship and I'm a first-time voter
in the United States so I want to show
you what that's like on my journey
the 2016 election is the biggest of my
life as a first-time voter not only did
I get to take part in the process but I
even got to meet my new hero but let's
start this from the beginning
coming from socialist Quebec it was
important to find the right candidate
who's fight for me after hours of
research on the Internet
I see that Bernie Sanders is just what I
wanted free collage free healthcare and
money for everybody it's almost like
Quebec
so I decide to go to his rally the
energy was crazy the line was so far
outside the parking lot good thing for
political entity and my wheelchair thank
you so much I was wondering at the Linus
thank you so much I got to the front of
the line but everybody is very support
even this black who try to give me some
free t-shirt you're giving away the
t-shirt and selling them hockey
I guess socialism is not for everybody
ha ha ha I make the joke and then for a
place that's one to include everybody an
open border they sure have a lot of
security the Secret Service were looking
at me like the only guy color at a
concert Celine Dion once inside I got to
meet all the different people and learn
why they too were voting for Bernie
people fighting for social justice
like the people who's not one to pay for
school
yeah I actually want to go to school for
eight years to get a degree in
psychology and then go to grad school so
school for me would be really expensive
love you have in the United States like
in Canada um how do we say Khurana
a college scholarship I'll be paying
money pretty much til I die if I like
have to pay all the money for every
single year in every textbook and I
think Bernie can like help - do you work
oh yeah I can imagine
but how do you get like like a phone
like that because in Quebec it's it's
very expensive
okay that's for sure even people for
Bernie with many sang wouldn't share any
with je as it possible you guys have to
sign we could have one
okay but you're together we didn't get
any can we have one we don't have any
shine they didn't give us no I know she
is like King right
I guess socialism isn't for everybody
I learned that it's only Bernie who's
nice to the bisexual community all right
is that your LGBT okay is that so what's
that stand for um lesbian gay trans GB
and then bye-bye okay yeah and you are
bye-bye okay but so not not T no and
that the cops are shooting everybody
you mean by like gangs and that things
like I'm now oh but I learned that
bernie is team up to solve the cup
problem with the former murderer is big
guy killer Mike he killed somebody but
bernie is forgiving guy even that killer
Mike open for evolution and for a guy
who's killed people he's really bring
people together ain't nobody's perfect
and Bernie himself has come a long way
from when he was a young he chained a
black woman that's good I'm learned that
many people don't want to pay for health
care
Gary
that's it
you know told that both let you live in
a lower socioeconomic class but still
get the same
yeah that's right yeah
and but did you ever do it in Canada or
were you too little you were born in
occupation and it's worked for them
but like me they also don't want to pay
more tax okay
okay like do we have like a number like
what's the best in in Quebec it's it's a
52% but everybody was true patriot me
the Pledge of Allegiance you know I
pledge allegiance to the flag you know
that that one of the United States of
America did you know that one you have
to do it too okay okay and to the
Republic for which it stands people were
so friendly everyone want to hear the
story of lucky or neither's all this
excite okay right for sure thank you I'm
excited but I'm not the hero in this
story it's time for born
and when he speak it's like he was
reading the mind of everybody I promise
everything the people one marijuana is
not I believe that health care is a
right of all people you gotta be talking
about making public colleges and
universities tuition-free
I know that every man in this room will
stand with the women and make sure
if I can they want comprehensive
immigration reform I agree
and a path
have a heart debacle yeah okay so you've
done marijuana twice in my life it is
acceptable to insult Mexicans and
Muslims acceptable to women and veterans
and these mentioned that bad guy a lot
Donald Trump I couldn't find them but I
found an employee
oh that's fast not like that thing is
more important than your selfishness for
you people the the 1% is tricking you
guide the community with their
selfishness yeah that's right
you're talking about me I was I paid to
finally end the truth now is the time to
get drops well I think we need the
football right now they talk about
welfare abuse poor people refusing well
forever
the mega largest welfare abuser in
America is the wealthiest family in
America and I say the walk will fail
take it from them I say to the Walton
family get off of welfare pay your
workers a living man
I was happy to finally hear the truth
but I was also mad so I was inspired to
do something to be punished these people
of the 1% are not like the people who
support Bernie and put it on the other
end I'm not even paid tax you know
that's the power I'm for the oculus make
sure people like that they know
with all of all different type young
people old people bisexual I was going
to say be proud of that one if she's
your daughter why she's open bisexual
you know an even [ __ ]
everybody was filling the bird I'm
looking for me I even get to interview
killer Mike that's I'm surprised he's
not here with security and everything
going up like that no no no I'm just a
regular person like you man all right
don't be too modest a celebrity like you
have a regular person man there's
nothing special about me I'm saying I'm
talking right killer he was so down to
hurt just doing anything that anyone can
do so like using your celebrity to get
people just news do you just use my
relations man that guy is humble and do
you think like Bernie he's been very
cool on Saturday Night Live and the
support is going to be on another do you
think he'll be like on the album like
the wrath out boom how I don't know
that's it that was enough for me if a
killer like Mike and turn his life
around and support Bernie that none of
us have excuse so I say to all the
people of America join the revolution
and come with me on my journey
comme si comme si comme si comme son
- sniffing come on come see come see
come see from son